[Music]
this is the Warner Brothers archive in
Los Angeles a prop warehouse that helps
preserve the history of one of
Hollywood's greatest studios and we had
the rare opportunity to take a tour we
have everything from cars as you might
see we have props we have over almost
30,000 costumes this is Bonnie Fallone
Auto she's the director of the Warner
Brothers corporate Archive and we have
some set up - she showed us props and
costumes that go back decades and
explain how they maintain them and why
the archive is so important oh and I may
have geeked out just a little bit wait I
just remembered that Leonardo DiCaprio
sat in this car oh my gosh is it snow
like it okay oh my god the first thing
that strikes you about the archive is
just how massive it is
[Music]
and there was still a ton of ground we
didn't get to cover the Batman movies
have been a defining property for Warner
Brothers since Tim Burton's iconic 1989
movie starring Michael Keaton and Jack
Nicholson so from which movies are these
Batmobiles from this one over here is
from Batman Returns those are the bat
missiles over here this is the spinner
car from Michael Keaton's Batman so it's
quite old
[Music]
they used it for it for a sequence where
the Batmobile spun around Wow
here is the George Clooney Batmobile
from Batman and Robin so now if you want
to sit in I can jump in I jump in oh how
does George Clooney fit in here Oh God
okay I'm scared to move and let's not
forget this giant tank like Batmobile
from Batman vs Superman and Justice
League it weighs eight thousand three
hundred pounds and is around 11.5 feet
wide it's not easy to move it from place
to place
sometimes productions need more than one
version of the same car
this was Joker's car from Suicide Squad
one of these cars can actually drive one
was just used for static shots and the
third one that's right
[Music]
but enough about Batman for a moment
there was another car I was really
excited about the Duesenberg from the
Great Gatsby custom job supercharged in
it wait I just remembered that Leonardo
DiCaprio sat in this car Wow oh my god
Leonardo DiCaprio's but we're here and
look at all of these costumes they're
stored in custom-made muslin bags that
help keep out moisture and it's a who's
who in there we saw some outfits that
were used in movies as recent as 2018 s
crazy rich Asians so this is the dress
that was worn in the engagement scene
and of course probably my favorite
outfit from all of the gowns and
everything was this that awkwafina's
character wore inside her home and then
we saw hats worn in my fair lady dating
all the way back to 1964
and that was worth when she returned to
Covent Gardens after she became lady
so the straw is in beautiful condition
yeah and and even even some of the
colours are still pretty much intact
especially delicate outfits are wrapped
in acid-free paper and put in acid-free
boxes to keep them in mint condition
there was also a wide array of other
types of props and set pieces so Margot
Robbie hello
and that's her bat
[Music]
we actually have the hair on it too
preserving pieces of film history like
this is incredibly important but it's
not easy this archive has been around
since 1992 before the archive was set up
there really was no protocol as to where
these assets were going so many times
they went home with cast and crew a lot
of iconic movie props puppets and
animatronics are made out of materials
like foam which sadly deteriorate over
the years when you're in production all
they care about is getting that shot so
a lot of times they're not made to last
and then they come here and we are
commissioned to do that we've got to
figure out the best way to make that at
least preserve the life of that problem
while the archive isn't open to the
public a lot of these props often go on
tour so you too can one day get a chance
to sit in the Batmobile
[Music]